how would the military in sudan deal
with the unrest the resignation of the
prime minister and growing public anger
have thrown the country further into
uncertainty could a new power sharing
deal be the way out this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm kim
vanell sudan is again in political
turmoil following the resignation of
prime minister abdullah it's come less
than two months after he was reinstated
under a deal with the military the
senior military leader general abdel
fattah al-burhan is calling for an
urgent caretaker government and new
measures to deal with the demonstrations
pro-democracy groups say the military
should stay out of government and
they're planning more protests a
political deadlock between all sides has
left the country unable to transition
from dictatorship to democracy since the
asking of long-time ruler omar al-bashir
back in 2019.
during a speech on state tv humdak said
more talks were needed for all parties
to reach agreement
we needed a round table for the
salvation of the country to come to an
agreement
i tried to spare my country the disaster
recently i met with all the civilian and
military officials of the transitional
council to address these issues
after i decided to return to you what
you have entrusted me and resigned the
position of prime minister
well let's take a look back at how this
started three years ago an uprising in
sudan forced the government from office
it began in december 2018 with protests
over the rising cost of living but it
soon evolved into calls for an end to
president omar al-bashir's 30-year rule
that led to him being overthrown by the
military in april of 2019.
a power sharing agreement was signed in
august that year abdullah humdak was
appointed prime minister leading a
transitional council
in february he announced a cabinet
reshuffle in the face of major street
protests against fuel and bread
shortages then last october the military
declared a state of emergency dissolving
the interim government and arresting
civilian leaders
since then thousands of people have
demonstrated and dozens have been killed
by security forces
all right it's time to bring in our
guests in nairobi
is a political commentator and managing
partner at insight strategy partners in
somerville alex deval is executive
director at world peace foundation at
tufts university and in doha we have
ahmed al-jayeli a lawyer and legal
commentator a very warm welcome to the
program to you all i'd like to begin
with you ahmed el-jali uh here in doha
is abdullah humbock's resignation any
surprise to you
it is not and despite all the headlines
i would i would describe it as probably
the most consequential irrelevant event
in in sudanese history it is irrelevant
because
as far as the people on the street are
concerned really lost his political
relevance the minute he went rogue and
signed that agreement with with burhan
on november 21st
it is irrelevant also because it's been
weeks in the making so it's not a
surprise
to anyone
yet at the same time this could prove to
be a fairly consequential event
mainly for the international community
which was content to move on from sudan
after the november 21st agreement and
maybe for the few remaining skeptics in
sudan because what this resignation does
is that it removes the last remaining
fig leaf from the october 25th coup and
it shows us chose it for what it really
is it's a full-fledged military regime
now and and that
in effect forces the international
community to re-engage and refocus in
sudan which might be a good thing for
the impasse that is happening and as far
as the the pro-democracy movement
although they have moved on beyond
handok and his agreement i think the
political vacuum that his departure
creates does create an impetus for them
to
move faster to try to present an
alternative to try to unify their front
and
prove to the world and to the rest of
the sudanese population that they are
able to unite and present a credible
alternative so
that's why it is simultaneously relevant
and and and irrelevant at the same time
we'll talk a little bit later about uh
the potential role of the international
community going forward but i'd like to
cross over to nairobi hold here where
does this leave sudan where does this
leave the protest movement where does
this leave the military junta and its
plans
well as ahmed pointed out you know
hamduck is just a
sort of his tenure represents a phase in
the revolution this is not in any way
the sum total of the revolution uh the
the democracy movement was there before
hamdurk it will remain there
um after his resignation and so this is
just now uh sort of entering a new phase
of the revolution one where the protest
the pro-democracy movement is
unencumbered by discussions around
whether hamduk should be given a chance
to make good on on the promises um or
whether he shouldn't you know that
conversation is now moot the bigger
conversation the much more important
conversation is how do we ensure that
the armies
goes back into the barracks and leaves
political and economic life for good and
of course on the on the military side
they now have to contend with a sort of
a new calculation both internationally
but also domestically the more they
double down
um and they have and they have been
doing so the more they become
sort of um the clear
overarching enemy without anyone to be
able to sort of put the burden on you
know hamduck is no longer there to blame
as part of the governance structure they
are the government um
unequivocally and what that means is
that their international backers mostly
in the region um are will be
increasingly unable to support them in
the same way because of the reputational
risk that arises from the level of
repression that we're seeing
alex de val why did abdullah hanbok
accept this deal in november in the
first place was it just because he was i
mean he was under house arrest right but
did he truly believe it would work was
it ever going to work
it was always going to be a an extremely
long shot
and i think he he was under extreme
duress he was very isolated and and and
the key failing was that he negotiated
really on his own he didn't bring in
the the
the full democracy movement or all the
civilian parties so he was isolated from
the beginning i think he had two clear
motivations one which would and both
were honorable one was to see if he
could prevent uh further bloodshed and
that didn't work out because the
democracy movement did not
accept uh
his
his compromise proposals and the second
was um
he
sees very clearly and perhaps more
clearly than anybody else the the
economic precipice over which sudan is
going and he really hoped that he would
be able to engineer
enough
of an economic bailout to to prevent the
worst um from happening now these he he
never had the political base the
political support in order to be able to
leverage concessions out of the military
the concessions that would have been
necessary for his his position to be
workable
and and and over the weeks it became
clearly unworkable and if there was a
surprise the only surprise was really
that he held on for as long as he did
before he quit okay ahmed el-jali i mean
the deal was that that was that was
announced last month was going to be an
independent technocratic cabinet under
military oversight
i mean was that ever going to be
acceptable to the people
absolutely not and i think that is
demonstrated by the continued
demonstrations on the streets the a very
cursory reading of that document of
november 21st will tell you that it was
just creating a civilian facade for
military rule the
every paragraph was echoing the
statement that rohan made on the day of
the coup and
he was given increased powers uh if i
recall correctly article four of that
agreement gave the the sovereignty
council full oversight over all
executive functions so hamdok's hands
would have been very tied even if he
wanted to do good he wouldn't have been
able to do and i think
he he realized that uh albeit a bit late
but he ultimately did
some critics of hamdock have suggested
that this not only lifts the veil on the
november pact but shows that even over
the past two years um since the toppling
of omar al-bashir that there was never
actually the real political will
to make a full transition to democracy
what's your take
i think that's fairly accurate on the
military side i think they have been
shown to be you know bad faith actors
when it comes to a lot of these
agreements that they signed including
the constitutional declaration of 2019.
um
one of the reasons of course is the
constitutional declaration itself
contained a coup clause that allowed
them this sort of out in order to be
able to take over um if they felt that
things were not going according to plan
of course that's a very ambiguous
statement and it gives them that sort of
latitude that they've been enjoying
pretty much since 2019. uh some people
have commented that you know this is
sort of the military buying time that
they've been buying time over the past
two years and now we're really seeing
this reconsolidation of the islamo
military project that we had under
bashir and we see this through you know
the sort of appointments to the security
sector appointments to the legal sector
as well as the new emboldening powers of
the security services um as well as the
other myriad uh security sort of um
advantageous policies towards the
security sector but what that means is
that
effectively
you know the past two years have been uh
this sort of experiment for the military
to see to what extent they could use the
civilians um as this fig leave and that
didn't work so well in the past two
years you know the civilians were able
to push through on some of their
priorities of course there were a lot of
challenges that they faced particularly
around federal governance the union's
law et cetera but really i think the
events pre just
prior to the coup and then of course
subsequent to to that really prove that
the military never really was in this
for the democratic transformation which
is again unsurprising for anyone who has
been watching sudan alex davao uh in his
televised speech mr hamdock said that
the country is at a dangerous turning
point that threatens its whole survival
do you agree with that sentiment
i i don't think he's exaggerating i
think that there is what we have at the
moment is a regime in
in power that is um in some ways is a
very familiar one there in some ways
this is you know we're familiar with
military dictatorships but that put on
the the the clothing the appearance of
of of nationalism of standing up for
saving the nation but in this case um
one of the the defining features of of
this regime
is the extent to which it has penetrated
the economy and especially rural society
it has militarized
much of the commercial sector and
increasingly the rural production sector
as well especially through
the number two in the regime
general uh muhammad hamidi and his rapid
support forces who are the de facto
governing power
in in darfur and many of the rural areas
and the depths of this
kleptocratic control
and the entanglement of this
kleptocratic system
in the region in with with egypt with
the gulf states etc means that this is
actually a a different
regionalized um form of of
military governments that will be harder
to uproot and i think this is really
what um abdallah hamduk has as a
conventional economist who had a vision
of sudan resuming a sort of
developmental trajectory he's saying
he's saying i cannot find a way back to
the economic and social stabilization of
sudan we are in the grip of this of of
this monstrous
trans-boundary military kleptocratic
system
ahmed el-jali i mean that is a very dim
uh grim
picture for the future
if in fact uh what we have is a
situation where the last two years of
transition inverted commerce has
actually to full democracy has actually
not been that at all
then how painful is is the next weeks
and months going to be for this protest
movement who are unrelenting in their
desire to see
a transition to a full democracy
i think that's the real challenge we
have the full determination of the youth
on the street to go on with their
protests and regain the freedom that
they've yearned for for years
and we have the generals who are
refusing to to to to give up power so
it's the classic unstoppable force
facing the immovable object um but if we
if we read the landscape we see that
sudan has been ungovernable for for the
military over the last two two months
since they've taken over and the
the demonstrations have only increased
um and i think with the departure of
prime minister handok the the inter the
internal pressure will be coupled by
increasing inter international pressure
uh and the the
military won't be able to continue the
bloodshed that they have started before
um for fear of increased international
pressure so they will be faced with a
menu of of three options um the first is
a negotiated exit where they step down
and leave the country and then the
second is a possibility of an internal
coup within the armed forces and third
is is is an armed confrontation some
type of civil war and i think we all
prefer the first option and i think the
increased pressure uh on on the on the
military will hopefully yield that
outcome and that's why we urgently hope
that the international community will
regain its focus on sudan and try to
avert option two on option three um that
could blink could bring a lot of
bloodshed that that can be avoided
how do you think the military is going
to respond to abdullah humbuck's uh
resignation and and do you think that
they will follow through on this promise
uh for elections in uh in what july 2023
i believe was the date
i mean as to the first question i think
they were initially worried about his
departure because they the reason that
they brought him back on the 21st of
november was so they could gain access
to international financing
uh obviously that has been materialized
because the international community
though it gives overt or tacit approval
to the generals it hasn't backed that up
financially which i think is a good
thing um but
in the middle of all that sort of
negotiation they have realized that he
won't um
that either the money isn't coming and
now with his resignation it's almost
certainly looks like it isn't so they've
been shopping around for a replacement
uh we've heard certain you know um names
including the former minister of finance
but of course nobody wants to sip from
this poisoned chalice because any prime
minister that is put in place now will
just like ham dog be seen to be an
accomplice
to the the murders and the killings and
the detentions etc and so they're going
to have a very difficult time finding um
a pm and in any case they are not the
body um constitutionally that appoints a
prime minister it is either the ffc or a
parliament which of course has never
been formed during this transitionary
period so they will find a very
difficult time to make it stick even if
they do find someone who's willing to go
in with them as for the elections
the you know elections in 2023 um only
benefit the the generals they only
benefit the islamist movement which is
still very much there in the background
and so i don't think i think everyone
will see through at a sort of early
elections egypt's style
as as the sort of theater of democracy
that rather than the actual genuine
commitment to it
and so i don't think they'll get
anywhere with uh early elections in
in by way of convincing people both
domestically and internationally it's
too soon anyway for many of the
political parties to commit to an
electoral process um only six months
from now
alex de val uh
will the international community do you
think increase its engagement increase
its pressure on the military as a result
of of this resignation what what what
can or might it do
well up to now the international
response led by the united states
um with europe in tow over the last few
months has been extremely feeble the the
internationals have very very strong
cards in their hands
because of the financial dependence of
sudan on on debt relief and on
multilateral international assistance
but those cards really have not been
played at all effectively what we have
seen particularly from washington
is that policy in the entire region and
the whole of the horn of africa has
under the trump administration was
essentially delegated to
israel egypt saudi arabia and the united
arab emirates they were given a three a
free hand to do pretty much what they
wanted in in in in sudan in ethiopia and
and in somalia and the biden
administration has not pulled that back
and
and essentially
the uh the calculation as i see it of
the generals is that they have their
friends in the region they have egypt
very clearly behind them um israel
through the extension of the abraham
accords the recognition of
sudan's recognition of israel is is
dealing directly with general burhan had
no interest in democracy and the saudis
and the emiratis as we know also have no
interest in democracy and now they are
patching up their differences with other
states in the region including
qatar and turkey that are also not in
favor of democracy and and these
states have enormous lobbying power in
european capitals
and in the us they have sold arms et
cetera et cetera we know that the
influence they have so what al-burhan
and hamiti are counting on is that they
ultimately will see out any uh any
pressure for democratization from
western nations because they have this
solid backing
in in the region and at the moment
washington london paris brussels are
doing almost nothing to disabuse them of
this preconception
ahmed al-jayeli do you agree with that
assessment in terms of the international
allegiances that the geopolitical powers
that play here
yes and no i think i think it's it's
pretty clear that sudan is is in a
difficult neighborhood so to speak uh
and i think part of the problem is that
the pro-democracy camp um
did a horrible job presenting its case
while they were in power uh for example
hamdok happily went on to european
capitals and to the us and completely
gave up the regional relationships for
uh for brohan and himeti
to to further cement the perception that
the pro-democracy camp is a threat to to
the interests of those uh regional
allies i think
there is a path where the pro-democracy
camp can present its case and can
present the reality that that one sudan
is ungovernable for these uh military
leaders and that
the long-term stability of sudan
will not happen without the street
getting what it wants and without that
there will be significant ramifications
for the region
which will be part of the national
security of those regional players so i
think there is an argument to be made to
to to the u.s europe and definitely
including the regional allies that
their long-term interest is actually
even if they don't agree with the
concept of democracy
but they have a vested interest in a
stable sudan and that a democratic sudan
is not going to be an exporter of
revolutions
but a place that is stable that is
economically stable that where they can
uh talk about food security talk about
regional security and we can have the
same conversations i think
uh other players might be a little
different i think israel russia and
others
who may have more nefarious interests
might be difficult to to to win over uh
but i think at least the the europeans
the americans and the regional allies uh
with some constructive dialogue can be
brought forward and i think
the possibility of american sanctions on
the coup leaders uh which is being uh
tabled now in the congress might change
the equation significantly because if
those individuals become toxic and
become a liability for their regional
allies i think we will see pressure by
those regional allies uh on those
individuals to step aside and and and
call for new military leadership that is
more willing to to heed the calls of the
streets
what's your take
what if any sort of pressure might make
the military backtrack hand over to a
full civilian government now and and
if you do think it's possible would that
be internal pressure from the protest
movement would that be external pressure
from the international community or both
it does absolutely need to be both uh we
can certainly bank on the domestic
pressure through the pro-democracy
movement what has been
not so dependable has been the
international pressure and it's quite
clear that the for the military you know
their main constituency is not a
domestic one um they all uh the
different generals um also however have
different countries that they sort of
rely on in a patron client sort of
relationship and so there is you know
when we say that the generals are sort
of more um
linked to or more engaged more with the
region that's not necessarily a monolith
that you know there are these sort of
individual
relationships going on as well um the
core problem is and you know to give the
hamdu administration their due they did
realize that the uh the military banked
so heavily on the regional players uh
mentioned before and so they did you
know try and make sort of overtures to
these uh countries in particular saudi
arabia and we did see some net impact uh
of that in the way that saudi arabia
in relation to egypt israel and the uae
responded to the coup um but of course
that's meaningless unless it actually
translates into pressure of meaningful
pressure transformative pressure on the
generals and that will only really come
about if there is a
concerted
shift away from sudan being seen as a
security
um through a security lens um
rather than through a foreign policy
lens where genuine partnerships economic
or otherwise can take uh can be
cultivated and so what we have right now
is you know pressure that is needed
essentially from the west on these
regional uh powers that isn't really
having the the impact and that's like
and that's due to a global shift in the
influence of western countries
particularly the us after the sponsors
trump policy of outsourcing uh regional
horn of africa policy to the gulf which
is which is a whole other discussion a
whole other inside story program in and
of itself we will have to leave it there
for time a big thank you to all of our
guests for joining us on the programme
alex dival and ahmed el jayeli
and thank you for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website al jazeera.com and for
further discussion go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation over on twitter our handle
is at aj inside story from me kim vanell
and the whole team here in doha bye for
now
[Music]
you